qui est membre de son fan club 3 9 ans
ils nous collent ces cons là on fait une
affaire personnelle on vient de devenir
leur pas expliquer leurs générateurs et
om sa part à toucher rectal de tomber
pts 1/3 vraiment pas ce qui pourra être
plus personnel base de sassetot alors
vous faites vos magouilles entre tout le
monde me suis ok je laisse tomber un
petit bowling
on sépare maintenant
tout
mon pote
[Musique]
ok la team écoutez bien ce groupe a
toujours été une famille et la donne
vient de changer
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dominic toretto roule tout
seul tu va tourner le dos à ta famille
je sais que c'est gras mais le lâchez
pas aussi vite c'est notre dernière
chance on va sembler à nouveau notre
famille je te garantis une chose
personne n'est prêt pour ça
elle est l'incarnation même du
terrorisme high tech
il ya des milliers de voitures dans
cette ville et là elle me glisse tout
maintenant je sais ce que ressentent les
flics qui nous prennent en chasse
manfred
on s'accroche
et autres
abu dhabi
cuba nos chemins se sont déjà croisés
d'hommes
sans que tu te rendes coup je crois
qu'il est temps de te rappeler pourquoi
tu as choisi d'être ici j'ai pas eu le
choix
pour rattraper d'hommes vous aurez
besoin d'un petit coup de main peut me
dire pourquoi tu fais venir ce buveur de
thé avec sa tête de crapule élevé au
pudding je crois que ces tee shirt trop
moulant ça empêche le sang d'aller au
cerveau tu te remettes une taille au
dessus vous deux vous allez bosser
ensemble
génial
[Musique]
depuis le temps que je pense
on a un tank
et à mon tour
yahia a pas
ils ne lâchent jamais la faire
je croyais que ce serait un combat de
rue
[Musique]
dis donc c'est pas le torpille tient le
voleur quoi
des singles et trop stylées sur ce coup
là whaou
je ne sais pas pourquoi tu fais ça mais
je sais une chose c'est que tu m'aimes
fin
wesh poulet les gars
[Musique]